pray and think of a way to kill myself
pray to God that I would die and asking
why am I being punished like this if he
knows I'm innocent
my name is Kenny Lee and I'm a solitary
survivor
I found it shocking that a person who
was accused of a crime not convicted of
a crime but accused of a crime could be
kept in such horrific conditions
the system has basically said too bad
you know you may be harmed by that may
we may have scarred you for life we
tortured you you lost your apartment
because you were arrested all of the
things that you had in your life that
created stability
when asada Shapira described the torment
and fortune she was not wrong my soul
died but my body is alive